e
aliance to the flag of the United States
of America and to the Republic for which
it stands one nation God indivisible
right all right um right I'm going to uh
first uh take up uh House Bill uh
313 and the chair recognizes
representative Perez for a motion thank
you um I move to retain this bill is
there a
second representa
to sorry which bill is this
313 oh yes I second all right
representative Perez would you like to
speak to your motion um it needs work
the bill needs work and um I think we
can tweak it a bit so it might be more
palatable and but as it is now it's not
ready for prime time all right anyone
else wish to be heard on House Bill
313 representative Smith I guess I i'
just say that um left to my DS I would
have um itl the bill but I'm always
willing to give people a chance to
improve um the bills that come before us
and so because of that I would support
the motion all right anyone else wish to
be heard on House Bill
313 all right seeing none the motion
before us is to retain and I would ask
the clerk to please call the
role Vice chairman Manion
yes
representative GS gas yes
G representative trip
yes representative Andrew yes
representative kutab yes representative
Perez yes clerk votes yes representative
McFarland
yes representative gzowski
yes representative Smith yes
representative Horgan yes representative
bur
yes representative Harvey
yes representative Manos
yes representative tur
yes representative Rambo
yes representative berson yes and
chairman Lynn yes 18 y zero nay all
right all right and since that's a
retain we don't need uh we don't need
um all right
um next I'm going to turn um to hb3
391 um
FN
um and um I would uh
recognize representative Smith or her
design for a
up 391 all right is there a second I'll
right all right um representative Smith
do you wish to speak to your motion um I
would wish to have representative bur as
second
bur thank you much for for that honor
um what I can say is about strategic
lawsuits against public
participation uh some people like them
some don't they uh address a specific
problem but they do close the door to
courtrooms uh in some respects uh I will
in the interest of full disclosure
indicate that I am a sponsor of a
different uh a co-sponsor of a different
anti slap bill from representative
buroughs which I think is a better bill
it's more focused on a specific problem
uh my belief is this this bill is far
too General and therefore the balance of
good and harm uh shift and therefore I
would recommend
itl anyone else wish to be heard so the
only thing that I would say I I I think
I generally agree with what
representative bur said the the thing
that I felt when we had this bill a
is I think it's very unlikely that one
of these slap bills actually will
produce the The increased time to
resolution of a case that is that is
claimed because I think it would be the
rare case in which it's not really
disputed whether the the intent or
effect of the of the lawsuit was to
hinder First Amendment rights my
suspicion is in most cases there will be
a big fight about that there will have
to be Discovery and so it will take as
long as it would usually take the other
thing that concerned me about this uh
bill is that there is at least some
language in the bill that refers to that
uses the term prosecution which could
arguably mean that this bill and
the so-called
expedited um manner of of disposing of
cases could apply to criminal cases and
it's a very general proposition in the
criminal law as I'm sure representative
Burch knows that there aren't any
summary judgment motions in criminal
cases if a if an indictment is returned
the case goes to trial so for all those
reasons I I share representative bur's
view anyone else wish to be heard on
391 all right seeing none um I would ask
the clerk to call the role the motion is
itl Vice chairman Manion
yes representative gas yes
representative trip yes representative
Andrew yes representative kutab yes
representative Perez yes clerk votes yes
representative McFarland yes
representative guzowski yes
representative Smith yes representative
Horgan yes representative Bur
yes representative Harvey yes
representative Manos yes representative
tur yes representative Rambo yes
representative berson yes chairman Lynn
yes 18 Ys zero
Nays uh consent any reason this can't go
on
consent all right consent and uh
representative Smith can I impose upon
you to prepare a report well could but I
would impose upon representa bir to ask
representative Birch would I not if you
wanted tonight because no no no not
tonight how about how about tomorrow
[Laughter]
morning um just come on you can take you
can take my report from last year and uh
have all right all right thank you a
blur a blurb of course yes all right a
blur
all right all right um next um you know
I'm gon to uh I'm gonna skip over 400
just because um one of the Reps that and
I frankly I don't remember who but one I
got a message that one of the Reps who
was interested in that uh would like to
be here if possible and can't be here
until two and what I told the person who
gave me that information is I would try
I'm not going to delay our proceedings
for this but if if I can accommodate her
by doing the other bills first I would
uh I would do that so maybe she can be
here to hear what we have to say so I'm
going to skip 400 and go um to four uh
62 um establishing a cause of action for
unwarranted video Imaging of Residential
Properties and the chair recognizes
representative McFarland for a motion
thank you Mr chairman I move itl right
is there second all right M
representative mfin would you like to
speak to your motion I'd be happy to I I
think that the bill on its face is uh an
issue which is not something that
warrants to be in the law and is uh one
that if it were in statute would create
uh some First Amendment issues and some
other property rights
issues right anyone else wish to be
heard on uh HB
462 all right seeing none I will ask the
clerk yes of course I don't I'm sure
you by chairman Manion I'm sorry I'm I
just wanted just to repeat it's it's on
House Bill 462 the motion before us is
itl so go ahead Vice chairman Manion
yes representative gon yes
representative trip yes representative
Andrews yes representative
kutab yes representative Perez yes clerk
votes yes representative McFarland
yes representative guzowski yes
representative
Smith representative Horgan yes
representative Burch yes representative
Harvey
yes representative Manos yes
representative
tur
yes representative Rambo
yes representative berson
yes chairman Lynn yes 18 Ys zero Nays
right uh consent anybody object to it
being on
consent uh consent and representative
McFarland could I ask you to write the
report the blurb I'll be happy to is
that required on consent it is it is
required yeah um just not on rain right
and um and if you could if you could get
it to me by tomorrow morning I'd
appreciate that sometime tonight or
sometime tonight he's even better he
already wrote
it um
uh all right um turning to F HB 509 FN
um uh the chair recognizes uh
representative McFarland for a motion I
move OTP is there a second I second that
all right motion's been moved and
seconded representative mcf Farin would
you wish to like to speak to your motion
certainly uh in the spirit of keeping
things brief I will say that I think
that the information that is requested
here is warranted and appropriate and
will be useful for further legislation
as we heard from the the bill sponsor uh
and I hardly recommend the bill anyone
else wish to be heard on
um I
have I really want other people to do
this but
um I
have no problem with providing
information um and and I think we do a
good job of providing information um and
I don't remember if it's four or five
items and I think they're quite
reasonable this list would require a lot
of items it require it will require
spending money which we don't like to do
to get the details uh that are required
it doesn't take into account the fact
that these are all matters that aren't
resolved within two or three months or
one year so that they come up again and
again and again and I think that um
there are better ways to spend um time
and money that would give us information
that could better inform our
decisionmaking than is required uh under
this Bill thank you anyone else wish to
yes representative Oregan and
representative CH yes I mean they do the
AG does Express the opinion that he
thinks the federal the feds would pay
for the cost of it but I still think
it's I'm sorry could could you repeat
that rep I didn't quite hear you oh I
I'm also opposed to the OTP and the cost
um it's the cost is significant and the
AG seems to think the feds would pay for
it but just given all the chaos in
Washington DC I think there's no
guarantee that they will pay for it and
even you know even they will pay for it
I think it's money that doesn't need to
be spent whether it's at a state or
federal level so it's an unnecessary
bill so I would uh so that's just one of
several reasons why I would not want to
vote for it right representative tur
yeah um I I also agree there there's
nothing sort of wrong with the content
that's being requested but as as I
brought up in the the hearing the idea
that it's not a unique report of each
forfeiture is troubling because it does
sort of feel like the same uh activity
could end up on multiple years of of
reporting and sort of uh exagger r or or
not allow us to duplicate the or UND
duplicate the the forfeitures that are
being that are being listed so I feel I
feel like something like it would be
good but this one maybe not anyone else
representative Burch thank you Mr chair
I I also am troubled a bit by it uh
because I don't think it's necessary we
already collect data we may collect data
on Five Points this will maybe add
another 15 points
but I'm not sure the cost of the
taxpayers because we have to collect the
data as well as collated put it out and
distribute it so there are significant
costs uh and it may be unnecessary the
idea of collecting it because maybe at
some future use we might want to have it
at some future time but we'll soak to
taxpayers now I think is is not the way
to go thank you anyone else wish to be
heard on 509 so I guess the the only
thing I would say and and um I was not
at this hearing but um what
was my understanding is that no one from
the AG's office was here for the hearing
or at least if they were they didn't say
um you know this is going to be
unaffordable we can't do this is going
to be a huge problem and it's and since
they are the ones that would have to um
be in charge of getting this information
that that is I think the fact that they
didn't say that is pretty significant so
for those reasons I intend to support
the OTP motion any yes representative
Smith could just respond to that
um
uh when the AG shows up here which they
do when they have to they are very clear
that they are not taking a position that
it is our job to set the policy and once
the policy is established they'll do
what they required to do so the fact
that they didn't come and say
um you know that they had problems with
this I don't think is um I think the
word would be causitive in terms of
having us decide it's rare that we get
something from the AG or from any
Department that says definitively that
they support or oppose a bill well I I I
guess I would say respon I I agree with
you to this extent I think it is true
that they rarely say take a position I
you know support or oppose but what they
often do do and in fact um I mean the
most recent example that comes to mind
uh is the hearing we had um last week on
uh
HB uh 195 and
522 they where somebody came and said
you know these here are some problems we
have with the wording and you should
change this or you should change that so
what I'm saying is I think what the AG's
office will do even if they don't take a
position on the bill if they see that
there's you know something is going to
cost a lot of money or there needs to be
additional resources or something like
that I my my experience has been that
they usually will say that kind of thing
and again I was not at the hearing but
my understanding is that they did not
say that at the hearing in this case
representative mcfar uh thank you Mr
chairman yeah I I believe you're correct
and on top of that uh my recollection of
the hearings that transpired that day
was that we had a number of law
enforcement officials here to speak
about not just that bill but related
bills and the topic of the information
around forfeitures came up and it was
clear from the responses that however
they may have felt on the bills they
felt that they had the information at
their
fingertips anyone else yes
representative Manos thank you Mr chair
um I would also oppose OTP on this um
one of the problem problems I see is
that the bill provides that the uh
attorney general would report 120 days
after the close of the fiscal year um
and that might CA take a case that uh is
proceeding over two fiscal years and
split the data about one particular case
between two fiscal years which seems to
me to defeat sort of to defeat the the
purpose of this um I mean it's very
possible that one case is going to
extend over uh more than one fiscal year
and then you end up with bifurcation of
the data and I don't I don't think from
a practical point of view that this
works very well thank you anyone else
wish to be heard on
509 all right seeing none um I would ask
the clerk to call the role the motion is
OTP Vice chairman Manion yes
representative G yes representative trip
yes representative Andrew yes
representative kutab yes representative
Perez clerk votes yes representative
McFarland yes representative guzowski
yes representative Smith no
representative Horgan no representative
bur no representative Harvey no
representative
Manos no representative tur no
representative ative Rambo no
representative
berson
yes chairman Lynn
Nays all right
um uh representative McFarland can I
call upon you again for the report and
right all right um I'd like to next turn
to House Bill 520 authorizing hearing
officers of the Department of Education
to issue subpoenas and uh the chair
recognizes representative kutab for a
motion thank you chairman Lynn I move
ought to pass yes is there a second I'll
second all right uh the motion's been
made and seconded representative kutab
motion I think
we've discussed this bill extensively
both last year and this year and I did
go through and I saw that there were
multiple
other departments which had allowed for
their either commissioner commission or
board to all issue uh subpoenas and the
doe the doe commissioner was essentially
kind of the only one who didn't have it
there were 10 other Commissioners who
all have it including the lottery
commissioner the revenue commissioner
the insurance commissioner the Labor
Commissioner
um It Go the L Dees the list goes on and
then there's several boards councils and
commissions including the Liquor
Commission and the executive branch
Ethics Committee
um so I just I think it's really
important that we make sure
that our commissioners have the tools
that they need need to get their job
done thank you anyone else wish to be
heard on HB
520 represent I'm sorry
got representative bur thank you um I'm
opposed to the OTP on on this um for a
host of reasons
probably I hate to relativ them but
certainly one of the more important
reasons is the doe came in and said
we've been able to get all the
information we want
already without this uh in-house
expansion of power so if there isn't a
problem why are we working on a solution
uh secondly we know that the attorney
general has the authority already to do
what this bill does and in essence this
is I don't know whether it's a power
grab or a Turf issue or whatever but it
seems as if the Department of Education
wants to run the show Itself by having
its own hearing examiner its own
prosecution so to speak of the case its
own subpoena power at the invest vatory
stage where the person being
investigated has no equivalent power to
compel evidence and witness uh Witnesses
for themselves so it's an unbalanced
proceeding it's an unnecessary
proceeding and um for those and probably
other reasons uh I urge the OTP to be
defeated right any uh representative
Smith um thank you I want wonder if um
uh someone um supporting the leg
legislation would help me better
understand um the connection between the
bill and the
testimony um the uh the bill says that
the subpoena um has to do with the
violation or possible violation of the
educator code of conduct
by a certified
educator um the uh code has to do with
child safety it has nothing to do with
curriculum and yet the
examples that have been given by people
who
support um
uh this bill all had to do with
curriculum
and um I I think that this is an attempt
to either have a sheep in Wolf's
clothing or a wolf in sheep's clothing
I'm not sure which but whatever it is I
don't think it is
um uh I don't think that the language of
the bill uh specifically
supports the arguments that have been
presented to us in favor of the bill
anyone else wish to be heard yes
representative
CA I'd like to also mention that every
other New England State they all have
this power um and so I really just don't
think that it's unreasonable for them to
have it the even in Connecticut Rhode
Island Maine Massachusetts and Vermont
so thank you anyone else wish to be
heard representative
ter uh I don't know if this would be the
appropriate time to offer an amendment
um I think I think we probably ought to
vote first on the OTP and then consider
the amendment well well no because
because I I think technically speaking
if you were to do that Mr chairman once
the OT passes that's it it's no okay
okay all right there was to be
consideration
Amendment okay all right no that's okay
it would have to be now all right so no
that's fine so representative tur uh do
you I turn the floor to you what do you
want to do did did you have a comment
before I would it be okay if I just
added a brief additional comment to my
comments of course of course thank you
Mr chair I appreciate the the leniency
on that I didn't want to forget the
concern I had that there's no protection
for Student Records in this
legislation and I'm concerned also about
that this bill would create an ability
to pea
children all right thank you all right
um all right so representative tur uh
yes so I i' I'd like to offer Amendment
uh 0842 H uh to House Bill 520 and I'll
speak to it is there a second for
that all right so um motion is um made
by representative
second all right uh yes representative
CH go ahead yeah thank you Mr chair so
uh let me summarize the amendment first
which is basically what it does is it
takes the um subpoena power as
originally written going to the hearing
officer and replaces it with the
attorney general
um we heard in our testimony that that
is done by a range of state agencies the
amendment was
drafted um based on a uh uh RSA
17041 part two um which pertains to um
uh child daycare residential care and
child placing agency so this is very
consistent with the IDE aidea of
uh hearings regarding uh standing lure
certification Etc which some of the
other agencies that we we just heard
about don't um don't get involved with
uh there's a couple of reasons why I'm
offering this uh building on I guess
what what representative Burch had
mentioned one um we have heard that
there's no uh there has not been a need
for this in the past so the idea of
creating a completely different
structure for hearing these um I don't
think is really warranted when we have
when we can simply allow um and this was
the testimony I Believe by the
Department of Education they're not
allowed to approach the AG for a
subpoena if we allowed that um than it
could be done through that standard
process without setting up another um
system the other thing that I think is
really almost more important and I think
is a sort of a structural problem with
the bill if it doesn't go this way is
uh the entire process refers back to
folks within the doe the hearing
officers work under the direction of the
commissioner of of the Department of
Education so the provisions that say
that you could make a motion to quash
The subpoena or challenge The subpoena
and the even the very idea that the that
the um the subpoena is Justified would
all be heard by somebody who works under
the the direction of the person making
the subpoena and I think that's really I
I can't see how you get around that
within the Department of Education this
I think offers us a a solution that that
provides everything that that was
originally requested so everything you
know there there there would be no if it
was a good faith subpoena request the AG
would have the power to do it and it
would provide all the access that the
department needs but without sort of
making it a a wholly contained function
of the department um of education so um
and and as you'll see the language of
the of the bill stays largely the same
it just largely replaces the concept of
the Attorney General with uh or the
concept of the hearings officer with the
with the attorney general all the other
protections and everything that were in
the original Bill are are still in place
so uh I don't see this as being
radically different in terms of effect
from what was proposed but I think it's
radically different in terms of uh
operational um implementation and
fairness so I'll stop there all right
anyone else wish to be heard on the
amendment so I guess what I would say um
with regard to uh the amendment is first
with respect to the issue of you know
the hearings officer works for the for
the commissioner I mean what you raise
representative ter sort of a fundamental
issue that has been litigated by the
courts for decades now in in the
administrative law context there's
always been that argument well the
hearings officer in this agency or that
agency is is responsible to the to the
boss of the agency how can they possibly
uh you know that's a some kind of a due
process violation they can't be fair uh
the courts have pretty uniformally
rejected that idea in the administrative
law context and there's no reason um for
treating it um uh differently here um
the other thing I would say with um and
Mr this maybe goes to both the um the
amendment and the the the basic bill is
to the extent representative Smith you
were saying you know there's no sort of
no need for this if I recall correctly
even at the last hearing we had on 520 I
think that there was some evidence
suggesting that there was at least one
case in which the department wanted
records and yes they eventually got them
but they had to the the school district
or administrative unit whatever wouldn't
released they wouldn't turn them over
they had to go down there and look at
them and they couldn't copy them um it
seems to me that that's an that's an uh
you know one at least one example of a
situation where um the to me the
fundamental concept is if you are a
regulatory agency and you're entitled to
conduct enforc or disciplinary
proceedings you ought to have the
ability to compel someone to provide the
information so that they can't say go
pound sand in one form or another
whether the go pound sand is we're not
giving them to you at all or you can
come down here and look at them but
we're not going to let you them you copy
them why because the Department of
Education is we can't trust them is that
is that the theory about why they
shouldn't be able to look at the look at
the uh look at the record I I'm sorry I
just reject that um so for those reasons
I plan to vote against this proposed
amendment but for the underlying Bill
anyone else wish to be heard can I can I
just clarify yeah that I I I I think
again speaking to the amendment um you
know it's I I don't know if you have any
comments I feel like it's still
preserves the ability to compel someone
it almost is more seems to me to have
more weight of it's coming through
through an attorney general's office
than through a hearing officer within
the Department of
Education all right um so I guess the
vote first will be on
Amendment um
0842 whether to adopt that Amendment and
since it seems like we have a
controversy about it I'm going to do
that by roll call vote so I would ask
the clerk to uh call the role on the
amendment
Vice chairman Manion
no representative G no representative
trip no representative Andrew no
Representative
cutab no representative
Perez clerk votes no representative
McFarland no Representative guzowski no
representative
Smith representative Horgan yes
representative bur yes representative
Harvey yes representative Manos yes
representative tur yes representative
Rambo yes Representative buron
no did you hear that was that a no I'm
sorry there was an L was that b it was a
seven Ys 11 Nays all right so the motion
fails
um all right we're now on to the um main
uh motion of ought to pass um as is um
and so I would again anybody want
anybody want anything else anybody wants
to say about the the motion on the bill
of ought to pass right in light of that
I'd ask the clerk then to please call
the
role Vice chairman Manion yes what's
this for representative gon yes
representative trip yes representative
Andrew yes representative kutab
yes representative Perez
yes clerk votes yes representative
McFarland yes representative guzowski
yes representative Smith
no representative Horgan no
representative bur no representative
Harvey no representative Manos no
representative tur
no representative Rambo no
Representative berson
no and chairman Lynn
yes 10 yays eight
Nays all right um representative kutab
can I ask you to write the report and
will there be a Minority Report yes
uh right all right umor and
representative CH is that okay yes all
right
uh
sure and that will be
um
representative
Minority Report will be O2
T okay all right with with his Amendment
that's yeah that's fine all right
um all right um next I'm going to turn
to uh
HB
587 um FN allowing the admission of one
party consent recordings in certain
circumstances and the chair uh
recognizes representative
McFarland um for a motion and perhaps an
amendment thank you Mr chairman uh yes
indeed I I move an amendment to HB 587
uh the amendment should be in front of
2025-the
the essence of Representative tour's uh
earlier Amendment as well as a number of
other changes that I thought to be
warranted and I'll just clarify them
because I see that OS has not you know
marked them in bold they've just kind of
replaced the whole language uh so the
changes that are embodied in this
amendment include as I said
representative T is one uh that you've
already seen and also uh in uh one uh in
section one where it changes and adds
the subp paragraph n um I have added the
words who is a party to a conversation
or who has the prior EXP explicit
consent of such a party uh so that the
uh the the statute if passed would
reflect that this is applicable only to
parties to the
conversation uh or their agreed designes
and not a a third party with with no
consent which is the way that it read
previously um the next change I've made
is I've added the the words intended to
be in uh subclause one and I've added
the words anticipates or in sub Clause 2
uh so those are the changes and I hope
that they are apart from that uh party
uh item that they are
self-explanatory right all right so I um
Manos oh your mic yeah sorry I'm sorry
um I wanted to just ask from
clarification from representative
McFarland
um you spoke about your last two changes
and I I wasn't able to pick up where
they were you said sure So in in number
one it says is intended to be provided
because I think um at the time that the
recording is
made it could not be provided to the law
enforcement agency at that time I I I
mean I I suppose one could dream up some
sort of live streaming scenario but I
think that's unlikely um so the the
intent seems to be the important aspect
there and then in number two um I think
that it is entirely plausible that
somebody might seek to record events
with the expectation that there's a a
crime uh going to occur um but they then
might be uh wrong and they might simply
delete the recording and I don't think
that that should be uh you know creating
a a crime
because they thought something bad was
going to happen and then it
didn't thank you other yes
representative
tur uh yeah thank you Mr chair so um I I
I support uh both representative
McFarland's changes and I just wanted to
clarify the the the component that I uh
and again ignore the separate amendment
that you have in front of you that I had
that I had drafted I wasn't sure if this
was going to come or not so um it's my
content is in here and all I did was add
um on line essentially line nine um and
is not publicly disclosed or released by
the person or their agent the reason I
added that I think the the testimony
around this entire piece of uh law is
that it's quite outdated it's been
around for a long time it predates
the the a lot of the the ways in which
recordings and such are used in the
modern in the modern context um and
there no attempts to change the
underlying process but um The Way It Was
Written it would essentially say if
you've um provided it to law enforcement
there were no other restrictions on what
you could do with it and I think for me
the intent was not to open the door to
you know giving it to law enforcement
then posting it on Facebook or or trying
to you know hear your case in in the
court of public opinion so I feel like
uh that ex that exclusion puts it back
within the context of of why in this
unique situation single party recording
could be
allowed right yes representative Manos
thank you Mr chair um I think that um
representative mcfarling and uh
representative tours uh changes are well
meant here but I read line nine as in
the disjunctive with the ores and so I
took this to mean that the recording is
not released by the person and to me
that meant for example if the victim
released the recording to their Pastor
or to their therapist or to a DV
counselor that um that that would not be
permitted under this amendment and I
have concern about that
um I have concern about that thank you
so I would oppose the amendment yes
representative um so I I it looked like
uh Mr chairman you might have been about
to speak there so I defer to you on on
the interpretation but I would say that
I think the intent is that the word
publicly uh is relevant here right that
that would be my interpretation too is
that that would not that that kind of
disclosure to a counselor or something
like that would not be considered a
public disclosure um and and just just
to add on during the hearing the word
the word solely came up as a possible
way to amend the language and I
specifically didn't go with that to
allow for those type of disclosures but
not public disclosure because solely
would have limited that can I just add
to that yes representative man so I I
think I see the confusion reading it as
public publicly disclosed or released
rather than publicly disclosed or
released which is which is I think what
the intent
is if that clarifies
problem
perhaps so I you know I guess I would
say is um oh I'm sorry representative uh
Burch
goad yeah so I'm kind of puzzled about
how both of these sections work uh or
subsections work so my first question is
is
intended to be provided to a law
enforcement agency or utilized in a
certain way um that intent presumably
does not have to be carried out it's
only an intent is that right
I respond yes of course uh so I believe
that is correct representative bur in
the example I gave earlier uh if and I
think one of the examples that we've
heard from the sponsors that they are
focused on in the reason they brought
this bill forward uh centers around
domestic violence and if we contemplate
uh domestic violence hypothesis where uh
there is a pattern of Behavior Uh there
is a
uh recording that
is set to take place of what is expected
to be a continuation of that pattern and
then that continuation does not occur in
that instance well there would be
nothing in that recording that would be
warranting providing it to law
enforcement agency or so forth so I I I
think that's what I'm going with it but
maybe I'm misinterpreting your
question all right to to go further
because still puzzled on that uh who is
encompassed this is a bit from
representative Manos by or their agent
so
if I I if
a just going to use gender wrong
language if a guy's calling up his
ex and the ex records the conversation
and believes there's something bad on it
uh of of this nature and they turn it
over to the
um
Coalition Coalition is considered their
agent sorry who's the Coalition oh the
uh New Hampshire Coalition against
Domestic and Sexual yes okay are they
now an agent of the uh purported victim
or are they an independent yeah I mean I
I think my response to that would be
that um I'm not going to speak for the
the underlying bill Bill and for the
purpose of the underlying bill I merely
saw this as a change that improved the
language of the bill now you may have
your own opinion as to whether the bill
is warranted and whether it's
appropriate to talk to council talk to
the Coalition you the language or their
that's represent that's what I was say
that's my language so I I can answer
that a little bit um the the intent and
you may or may not disagree that it
captures it but I tried to be very
specific about the way this was worded
by saying their agent it meant that they
are not giving it to someone else for
the purpose of public disclosure so if
they gave it to you know their Council
and you know if if if they didn't intend
through their aid directly or through
their agent to have it publicly released
you know there's once something's out in
the world it's hard to limit what's
going to happen to it um I think to the
extent possible hopefully the intent in
the language makes it clear this should
not be publicly released but you know
with without sort of limiting what the
person who made the recording can do
with it to further their court case but
still making it clear that they can't
release it and they can't authorize
someone else to release it was the
intent could I just clarify the the
agent question a little if if because
I'm not talking about an attorney who
has obligations to keep things
confidential that between her and her
client unless otherwise agreed I'm
talking turning it over to an agency
such as the Coalition uh would that be
would would that run a foul of this
amendment wouldn't the wouldn't the
circum wouldn't it depend on the
circumstances in other words if
the it would seem to me that that might
be something it would depend on the
particular circumstances of the cas I
could I don't know exactly how the
Coalition operates but if they were
providing you know if they were going to
be the agent some kind of a counselor
sort of similar maybe not in terms of
providing legal expertise but in terms
of their obligations to the client
similar to a lawyer then I would say
that that they probably would be an
agent if they were if you know if they
were just if the uh I mean if for if for
example the the the person who made the
recording um understood that the the
council was going to issue a press
release based on this recording once
they got it then I would say that if the
if the person turned it over to the to
the Coalition they would be violating
this provision um so that's what I mean
that I I read the word agent to mean
you're somebody that's acting in the
interest of the person who turned it
over but they okay if I could just
follow up on the word anticipates
because because I think we've covered
agent
enough um I don't know who to direct the
qu oh all right
so I I am
a yeah so I am a um putative victim of
domestic assault the other the other
person has a history of calling me and
and on some call
is abusive and some calls
not and I pick up my phone and that name
is
there um under
this
amendment there really isn't any reason
to to Bar me from tape recording every
one of the messages from that person is
that right or calls so I'll answer that
in two parts I think first of all the
notion that
um there can be something which would
rise to the level of of law enforcement
action on a phone call um maybe I'm not
familiar enough with the law but that
seems to be absurd in the example you're
raising and I I would not um be uh
expecting this to be used to claim abuse
over a phone call I would expect however
that if you had given me a similar
example in person in a room uh where
there's a history of uh somebody beating
their partner let's say um and that
doesn't happen on that one occasion now
you say to me well would that give you a
right to be recording on a continuous
basis um I think the question at hand is
what is what is done with the recording
and whether what is done with the
recording meets the the letter of the
statute as it would exist with this in
in in place and so it comes back to the
question of how you're using I think um
if you look at the uh uh what is it RSA
570a right there's a whole bunch of
exceptions in there of which this would
just become another
exception all right um anyone else have
any anything further to say on this so I
guess I I think personally I think this
is an important uh uh bill because it
offers the protections that
representative McFarland and
representative tur pointed out I think
it is it seems to me that the wording is
you know is appropriate could there be C
circumstances where that have to be a
court would have to construe it sure but
I think it's it sounds to me to be
pretty clear language the other thing I
would point out and I really I
representative McFarland pointed this
out to me last night at our uh at our
caucus on this on on a number of bills
and I it was really an excellent catch
because I I think probably in relying on
the the the title of the bill which
talks about one one party uh consent I
had been assuming that this amendment
dealt with one party consent but as he
quite properly pointed out it didn't
have that language in it and so if we
had passed it without that provision I
mean at least arguably it would have
allowed any non-law enforcement officer
to in effect conduct a wir tap where
nobody was consenting and the person was
um and this person was just recording
conversations so I think it's a it was a
very good catch representative McFarland
uh in some I think this is a good uh
bill and I intend to support the otpa
with representative McFarland's
Amendment anyone else uh have anything
they want to say yes yes sir so I just
wanted to touch real quick somebody had
mentioned um therapists chaplain vet
reps Etc uh those people are already
sworn to privacy unless there is
reasonable um like very reasonable need
to turn it over to law enforcement only
and violating that privacy is covered
under law and under social contract and
under medical contract and a clergy
contract so talking to an entrusted
person in that capacity is already
protected under law and that's not a
risk in this bill all right anyone else
have any comment so I'm I may be wrong
but it sounded to me like there was
generally a consensus on the amendment
so does anybody object if why we if we
vote on the amendment by a show of hands
if anybody does I'll do it by roll
call all right so then on amendment
0843 can I ask all those who are in
hand
so 16 all right 16 and those opposed
amendment all right then on the uh bill
as amended um so it would be otpa on 587
with Amendment
0843 anybody else want to have any
comment they want to
make seeing none I would ask the clerk
then to call the role uh on the otpa
Vice chairman Manion
yes representative gon yes
representative trip yes representative
Andrews yes representative kutab yes
representative Perez yes clerk votes yes
representative McFarland yes
representative gzowski
yes representative
Smith representative Horgan no
representative Burch no
representative Harvey
yes representative
Manos
no representative tur
yes representative Rambo
no representative berson yes yes and
um representative McFarland can I call
on you again for the majority report and
will there be a Minority
Report there will be but I want to see
if somebody other than me on those five
votes will do it otherwise I
will representative Smith do you have
any view on the who should write the
minority
representative bir might be out of my
place all right representative bir for
right I know I feel the wheels quite
over me all right
um
um sure it's uh there was is is there
somebody here that was interested in
House Bill 400 you are the one okay you
are the person that was all right so so
I'm going to turn we'll go to we'll take
up uh House Bill
um and uh hang on one
second uh the chair recognizes
designate I I guess I can't designate
representative Burch
um um Mr chair I move itl all right is
there a second
second I'm sorry who second
okay all right uh representative Smith
motion the
way
people get to yes the way they reach a
compromise the way they balance
competing
demands
um uh has a mix of both private and
public
responsibilities um when we're um
dealing with a public body
um I believe that
um we can end up with a much
better result
if we recognize that certain parties in
negotiations can negotiate among
themselves um in a more effective way
privately and each of the groups of
course can negotiate among itself as
they try to reach a
resolution um I don't believe that the
public interest is really gained by um
adoption of this particular
legislation anyone representative
organ well yes well this applies only to
the the management side of the labor
contracts because a union uh a union
local is not a government body and um
they're and so they're you know they
appropriately would discuss have their
discussions um about the contract with
themselves and it's probably
um a bad idea to force the uh you know
the negotiating committee on the other
side and the government side of it to uh
be unable to negotiate in private
because uh talk amongst themselves in
private because
um well I guess because I think what we
want to do is get to yes and reach a
consensus about a contract which both
sides like and so the uh the management
side would would be uh impeded in
getting you know in getting to a
contract which you know the uh which
their counterparts on the union side
would like and I think there is a there
this seem to be a feeling somehow that
if we did this the public you know the
public management negotiat would be
really really tough you know they
wouldn't make any concessions and that's
that's not necessar a good thing that
they're being really really tough and I
don't even know if that would be the
case they might actually most cases the
public is probably pretty pretty
sympathetic to the uh public workers who
are trying to get a contract they might
actually be easier on but anyway it's
easier to for them easier both sides to
be negotiate have the same um you know
be able to negotiate have the same
rights to to you know speak amongst
themselves before they uh before they
agree to anything and um also of course
this could in any case be circumvented
by bringing a third party so if you had
like If you hired some lawyers that ever
to negotiate on your behalf they
wouldn't be a public body so they would
be able to like uh discuss it but that
just kind of comp cases the
decisionmaking process I've probably
gone on too long but anyway this is a
this is this is not a good bill we've
killed it before and we should kill it
again this year thanks anyone else wish
to be heard on uh
hb400 yes representative trip I agree
with representative
Horgan anyone else wish to be heard um
so I guess what I would say
is I have mixed feelings about this on
the one hand I I I sort of agree with
the idea that why shouldn't this be
public but I'm I'm concerned about the
unintended consequences and the
implications of um what what a
negotiation in public could could end up
looking like and would there be you know
would these become sort of political
events where the uh the troops so to
speak from both sides show up to uh to
the to the negotiations uh so on on
balance I I I will support the itl
motion anyone else um have anything they
wish to say yes representative
Perez thank
you I understand what you're saying but
I think both sides at this point are so
concerned about their taxes
and what their money is being spent on
that everyone has a right to the
transparency of different things that
are being negotiated right
representative Anderson then
representative
man thank you Mr chair I understand both
sides of the
equation but something has to and I will
vote to itl but something has to
change last week I went to a school
meeting one of the warrant articles was
wages but none of us know what's in that
contract until after the fact and I
think it's sad that something I think
they could have negotiations on Zoom you
I mean you don't have to let the public
you know be in you know interact with it
but they could know what's going on
thank you represent man yeah to to
answer those
questions the only thing that the town
is voting on is the money being
allocated and that's and you have an
opportunity during deliberative session
or town meeting to do just that the
inner workings of the contract vacation
days grievance procedures promotion
procedures to have that be public and
open would just would be impossible to
negotiate a contract that way your
opportunity to speak on the money being
allocated is there it's during your
deliberative session or your town
meeting so thank you all right anyone
else wish to be heard on um on HB uh 400
seeing none well I'm sorry yes um so
having sat on both sides of the table
when contracts were negotiated I have
found that you actually are able to um
achieve a better contract for your town
when you don't have all of the noise of
the people who are listening in around
you you actually are able to accomplish
more for your constituents when you can
uh bargain in a calm um and respectful
and um way that keeps the wishes of your
constituents in the front of your head
as you're
bargaining anyone else wish to be heard
on
hb400 all right seeing none so um I
would ask the clerk to call the role the
um on uh HB 400 the motion on the floor
is itl vice chairman Manion yes
no representative trip
yes representative Andrew yes
representative kutab
Perez clerk votes yes representative
McFarland
no Representative gzowski
Smith representative Horgan
yes representative Burch yes
representative Harvey
yes representative Manos yes
representative tur yes representative
Rambo
no chairman Lynn
Nays all right um representative Smith
yeah you you have uh the pleasure and uh
Report not seeing any all right no
minority
what okay all
right all right um hang on all right
representative Perez will write The
Minority
Report all
right all right I have a qu I have a
question if I wanted if I ever wanted to
like either if I all of a sudden saw a
sentence that would make me want to
change my vote how do I go about doing
that think think you if you want to
change your vote on that's on this you
talking about on the last vote we just
yes exactly if you want to change your
vote i' I'd say now is the time to do it
either do it now or forever hold your
peace
now do you want to change your vote I
did all right well then you have to so
so would you like to change your vote
all right I'm I'm going to allow that so
what do you you I think your vote was um
against the itl motion so do you wish to
change
that so you now wish to vote in favor of
the I
motion all right so the vote then
changes from 13-5 to
14-4 is that correct corre yes all right
all right all right um that's fine
um all right uh so we still have
representative Smith will write the
majority report representative Perez
will write The Minority Report all right
Mr chair yeah if I could just make one
comment one of the things that works
very well in this committee is that we
try to accommodate
individuals um to be
consistent um in this it would if you
want to change your vote you really have
have to be paying attention because it
should be
before the vote is announced once the
vote is announced um now you can go back
but it's it works more smoothly if you
know if no no you just ask is everybody
okay with their votes or something like
that and then you announce the vote no I
I I hear you and I think you're I think
you're right I'm you know I try to I I
try to accommodate people when I for
which we are very
appreciative um all right um 601 I think
we are now up to
um
601 uh relative uh to causes of action
against companies that misstate the
environmental impacts of their business
the chair recognizes representative trip
for a
motion I move itl right is there a
second um I'll second
um representative trip do you wish to
speak to your motion yes I do
uh when uh representative Reed
introduced the bill I was a little
surprised and she said that well this is
the first time around so I'm I'm really
looking to
uh get some feel of uh what the uh
committee thinks and that uh you know I
be I'm and that she would be more than
willing to work with the committee to
make any changes well uh the hearing
proceeded and uh nobody asked any
questions I think the only person asked
any questions was rep representative tur
and that was the only question so uh if
she was in intending to improve the bill
by working with the committee you know
that was an object
failure
uh I do believe that I agree with
representative Reed that the bill needs
a lot of
uh is just uh it's full of exemptions
for someone that wants to uh be against
uh
uh climate change or whatever but anyhow
the the bill introduces it consists of
I I would uh consider it
uh falsehoods in uh advertising and uh
uh I believe that is a very subjective
thought you know because uh if I was an
advertising person I'm I'm sure I would
stretch the truth but not make it you
know false but uh you know that would
probably give someone that's uh looking
to uh get after the uh fossil fuel
companies you know
ammunition and uh but uh another
another item that I think is
uh a poor choice is that anyone wishing
untruthful deceptive or misleading
environmental marketing or untruthful
deceptive or misleading Net Zero claims
is that the person bringing the the
action doesn't have to
uh have
uh suffered any ascertainable loss
because of the uh either the marketing
claim or the uh zero Net Zero claim I
think that would be a that'd be a bad
idea uh and that
uh this would be very tempting for
lawyers to keep these companies
busy uh are you saying that could this
could be the lawyer's Full Employment
Act is
that
well there are some there are some words
that could be changed here uh but the
one that I really like is in the uh
right of action for harms connected to
climate change is uh
in the major disaster
meaning uh they include tidal waves
tsunamis earthquakes and volcanic
eruptions now I I have a hard time
believing that uh uh fossil fuels are
causing these
problems and uh that's why I uh believe
that the the bill should be itail and uh
sent back for forther work all right
anyone else wish to be heard on uh House
Bill HB 601
F all right seeing none uh the uh motion
before us is uh itl on House Bill 601
and I would ask the clerk to call the
role Vice chairman Manion
yes representative gon yes
representative trip yes representative
Andrew yes representative C to yes
representative Perez yes clerk votes yes
representative McFarland yes
representative guzowski yes
representative Smith yes representative
Horgan yes representative Burch yes
representative Harvey yes representative
Manos yes representative tur yes
representative Rambo
yes representative B on
yes chairman Lynn yes 18 y zero
Nays all right any reason that can't go
on
consent all right consent and uh
representative trip could I ask you to
uh prepare the
you
Vol all right I think think we're up to
the last one on our list uh house bill
um 614 uh FN and the chair recognizes
representative Burch for a motion uh
thank you Mr chair I would move itl all
right uh I will second the motion
representative Burch do you wish to
speak to your motion uh thank you Mr
chair um there's a number of
difficulties in this bill um one there's
no limit on what are considered nominal
damages uh that the court could aware
could award I mean normally it's a
dollar it could be $5 but here it could
be any unlimited amount there's no
uniformity of
application the bill makes no difference
between an intentional violation and a
non-intentional violation there's no
requirement of malicious or recklessness
which is a federal standard for punitive
damages and in essence this bill could
easily
shift um nominal damages to punitive
damages um but not call it punitive
damages um we're talking about cases
even when the grief citizen says there's
no monetary damages at all uh and the
odd situation where let's say there's a
search and seizure and it's determined
to be
lawful it's DET to be unlawful based on
a new interpretation of the law by the
court uh but the officer felt that he or
she was doing fine under a prior uh in
in uh in
effect uh application of the law my
reading is uh damages could still be
awarded uh it's there's a lot of
problems here thank you anyone else wish
to uh be heard on this um I guess the
only thing I would say I agree
completely with what the points that
representative Burch has made the only
other thing that I would say is um to
the I I think that there is a real
question of the need for
allowing under state law a right of
action to to allege a constitutional
violation because most I'm not saying
absolutely everything but the vast
majority of things that could be
characterized as a constitutional
violation um under state law probably
constitutes some kind of common law tort
whether it's defamation or invasion of
privacy or uh assault or battery or
false imprisonment or uh whatever um I
think almost all of them would uh almost
all of the things that could be
characterized as a constitutional
violation would meet one of those things
maybe there are a few that wouldn't but
um for the reasons that representative
bur says I think that that's um that
there's no reason to have this bill so I
would definitely support the itl anyone
else wish to be heard all right um I
think oh I'm sorry oh yes representative
McFarland thank you Mr chairman um so I
I think that we have
heard opinions that there are reasons uh
for this bill um and I guess you know
some of the examples that have being
presented to
me uh resonated strongly with me as as
being real world examples that that I
see uh just you know in my own district
and in my own conversations and for
example um I was having a conversation
just in the last couple of months
around uh a student who was being
disciplined for things that she had said
outside of the school outside of the
academic environment
um and I I think
that you may be able to come up with
some other avenues uh that that would be
available there I'm not sure that I can
come up with them um but I do think that
this is an appropriate Avenue uh to to
put in
place anyone else wish should be heard I
I guess what I would say on that in
response to that representative
McFarland is again without knowing
exactly what the
circumstances um it would seem to to me
that that would very like if somebody if
what somebody said was was used as the
basis of disciplinary action it would
seem to me that that would at least
arguably be the basis of of some kind of
defamation that you that you know we you
said something that uh that cause that
was the basis for us taking disciplinary
action against you so that you know can
I say that for sure no but I think
it it it likely would fall within that
so anyway that's that's my U response
anyone else wish to be heard all right
so I uh the motion before us is itl on
House Bill uh 614 and I would ask the
clerk to please call the
role Vice chairman Manion yes
representative gon yes representative
trip yes representative Andrews
no representative cab no
representative
Perez clerk votes yes representative
McFarland no representative gzowski
yes representative Smith yes
representative Horgan yes representative
Burch yes representative Harvey yes
representative Manos
I tell uh
yes
Representative no you got it right I
think don't ask me representative Rambo
yes representative berson
yes and chairman Lynn
n all right um
uh no that with four votes
against um yes I'll do the BL thank you
representative bir for the majority who
is there going to be a Minority Report
there will apparently my evening is not
busy enough all right uh all right thank
you representative McFarland um
minority all right um I think we
are done
um and that actually it's a lot quicker
than I thought it was going to be um um
so you know what I want to uh the one
thing
um oh yeah yeah yeah I know the um
that's a good point so uh you know what
two things to take up one is next week
the 19th we are um I am likely and I and
representative trip I apologize because
I know you asked me what if we were
going to have something next week and I
think I said no and I wasn't thinking of
this next week we are trying to arrange
to have um the legislative budget
assistant and someone from the AG's
office and maybe the Human Rights
Commission um here to to uh for a
hearing on the uh the audit the
performance audit report um I haven't
okay you know what I'm sorry they are
available okay all right so I I'm
hopefully then we'll be able to do that
um the other thing uh and I hope I have
that material with me I think I do but
I'm not positive um yeah um I wanted to
spend a minute if I could to talk about
the the information I sent out we got a
this letter from representative uh Wier
about the uh the budget um you know can
you give me excuse me for just a second
while I get I think I have it in the
bring where else are they going to go
me uh so
um I wonder if we could just take a
minute to kind of go
through um so the first taking in order
the first
um uh item that representative y and the
finance committee seem to raise a
question about is um the board of tax
and land
appeals and it appears that there's a
suggestion that they want
to
remove um this this is not this
is
come is house bill to right okay
so I'm sorry I was on the impression
this that this came from I sent it to
you but it comes from house two okay
right which was presented to them by the
by the governor oh okay um that well
they propos apparently to uh eliminate
the requirement that the board have an
appraiser and that the board have a
clerk
um I you know
I and you don't see how they can do
their work it would be uh especially the
clerk it seem like that might be a might
be a problem not having a clerk um any I
mean that my view would be to
say I'm very sensitive to the budget and
and I have to say that the I I think
getting an appropriate budget would be
in my personal view the most important
priority but you know to the extent
there are choices to be made
I would say at least for the clerk
that's not a good idea and probably for
an appraiser since that's a large part
of what the btla does um anybody and
they're not required they're not
required to be appra in order to be on
the board no that's true that's yet yes
representative mcfar so I would say two
things the first is that I do not read
the changes uh as indicating that they
shall not have a clerk I just read it
that they're taking out the requirement
to have a clerk appointed by the board
as a classified state employee it does
say the board shall have such clerical
staff as may be necessary and may employ
such other staff as it shall deem
necessary um the other aspect of it
though with regard to the
appraiser um you know I I I think if it
were as simple as that we were getting
rid of the appraiser
um then my view would be that the lack
of the appraiser is maybe worse than the
lack of you know more more Troublesome
than the lack of the clerk but I think
to be honest in that case the same holds
true it it talks about uh having such
technical staff as may be necessary and
employing such other staff as it should
deem necessary so I'm not sure that
these these two sentences that are
struck there really indicate that they
cannot bring on whether it's on a
Consulting basis or on some other basis
the the skill sets they need no well you
no you may be right I mean I guess my my
inclination would be that I will say to
representative Wier look we have we have
concerns if the um if the result of
these changes would be that there's no
that there's no appraiser or no clerk
for the board if the language permits
the board to continue to do those things
um that that mitigates it um but those
are our concerns representative Perez I
think they're giving themselves the
opportunity to have these positions in
an as needed basis for example if they
are do not feel for a particular case
they need an appraiser and might be able
to use an appraiser that an appraisal
that was already came from a town or
whatever then they don't need it if they
feel that they don't need a clerk and
they can take notes and go from there on
their own it gives them them the option
of not making of coste
Effective Government how's that okay so
I I don't disagree with that I've um put
I'm a little skeptical about not having
a clerk just uh for for an adjudicate
but you may be right I'm I'm I'm not
saying you're wrong all right
um uh the next one is I'm sorry
excuse me are you going Mr Char are you
going through paragraph by paragraph I
wanted to comment on RSA 498a col 16 oh
sure yes may I comment yeah of course um
this is the bill uh we just worked on
this bill I I think it was two weeks ago
uh and we made changes to this uh I'm
not quite sure how the crossed out
language um affects the budget decreases
the budget or maintains the budget
um I can't imagine that the board of tax
and land appeals is being charged to use
County cour houses and we changed uh the
B the statute so that um the
parties if they can't meet at the court
County Courthouse if one of them
requests that that then they meet at the
office the board's office in conquered
so I'm I'm confused used as to how this
would be a budgetary you know I think my
impression is that this was I mean the
language in in what we have before us
was be obviously before there was the
change that we made um so
um you know I think in some
sense I mean I would assume that the to
the extent that it says that
um uh the uh the hearing shall be held
in the county in which the Declaration
is filed unless the parties agree to the
extent they're taking that out I assume
if the if it's a money-saving intent
they would the the idea would be that
the board would be able to sort of
compel people not to be in the county if
they if it would save money our bill
doesn't say that um and who you know um
I don't know what I don't know what
Finance would do with that ultimately
yes well I I don't know either but it is
one of their options incorporate our
bill into hb2 and also if if we pass hb2
with this language and our other bill
with our other language um they both go
to the Senate and the Senate might uh
incorporate our change into its version
of the uh hb2 although you know we don't
really want to count on them to do
anything
but yeah no I I hear so I you know I
guess
I'm the way I understand this process I
I thought it was appropriate to get
input from everybody here and I will try
to you know convey that to uh chair Wier
obviously I'm not on the finance
committee so Finance is gonna kind of do
at least in terms of what they recommend
they're going to do what they're what
they're going to do and I will try to
express our uh concerns on some of these
things give the language of the bill
sure that we yeah that we right well you
both you R Smith are alumni the finance
committee does it that's that's true she
is far more experienced than fin I just
spent one term there that's uh um that
was
enough on uh the next item is
um appears to deal with
removing
um uh
from the
provision let me see yeah from the
um from the provision prohibiting the
um the private practice of law if I'm
reading this correctly um so the
provision of this section shall not
apply to the direct so that the director
of charitable trusts would be covered by
the provision of not
um not practicing all I don't I mean I
to me that's this is an issue for the
for the AG's office that's where the
charitable trust is
located I would basically say that
that's not what does the AG say about
um uh the next one is um if I'm
understanding correctly from from
representative wier's markings on this
it deals with the
uh add language that would allow the
judicial
Council
um to
um not have to
produce um records that are under
seal um held by the executive I mean
it's listed under judicial account
records held by the executive branch
that are not under seal to the extent
I'm understanding ing this or
confidential in a court
file again
um representative Smith as the newest
member of the judicial Council um I have
um whatever the title was head of
judicial councel who um executive
director executive director thank you I
knew it wasn't a commissioner I just
couldn't remember who uh um is quite
comfortable particularly comfortable
right I I don't see this is what this is
what he sent yeah it's like this seems
I I
don't I don't that may be you know what
that may be language that that the
governor's office sent of some you know
proposed change but I don't think it
applies to us right yeah so then you go
on to the judicial Council section right
yeah
um
yes the next one is
um um dealing with compensation of
council I'm I'm on now on page 5 what's
labeled at the bottom 57 of
um and that's the judici right inv voice
yeah so this um and there you know of
course as we all know there're
struggling I mean there three ways that
we get appropriate legal council and um
they have no choice but
to but to provide that Lal Council and
they get build for it and some of the
costs are lower than other costs and
they're just trying to stretch that
dollar yeah I I mean my I
guess I know representative Smith
probably just before you were appointed
I know that the we the judicial council
did uh propose to the Supreme Court to
make some changes uh I think both
in uh well I think it was mostly the
rules but basically to to say that
within a certain limit the judicial C
the judge could just approve certain
expenditures which seemed to me at the
time to make sense
now I I guess my take on this
is I don't think what is anything that's
in
here really addresses the the the issue
of what are they going to fund
how are they going to fund the judicial
Council if the you know whether there's
going to be more or less funding is
that's hpit one is right is an is an
issue but
this you know I don't know that it
matters that much depending on what the
funding
is so that they seem to think it would
it would ease the way it would be the
appropriate way for them to continue I
guess is what I don't want to use the
word ease because I don't think any of
it's EAS right I mean I suppose in some
sense maybe the th the thinking is that
if you if the and I I'm not sure what
how much this would save but if the if
you don't have to go through the process
of having the the judicial Council send
it to the judge have the judge sign off
on something that which is just sort of
extra paperwork maybe that saves a
little money I
I I'm skeptical but maybe
um all right um and then sorry there was
uh you know what I I think I skipped
over one thing that I think is actually
pretty important there is uh you'll see
on page 51 of
77 there with regard
to children in dependency proceedings
there is a proposal to
extend the dates in
which
um the appointment of council
for children is
um for lack of a better term is sort of
fully um implemented and let me uh I I
asked the
um for the copy of the original bill
from uh
2024 that is referenced there
um hang on one
second no they're they're extend they're
they're pushing out the time within
which Council within which the statute
requiring Council in certain cases in
dependency cases takes effect and I
think the in other words the idea is to
save money they want to they want to
push it out for a couple of years to
save some money was this the CFL bill
on court appointed Council for kids um
it's it's the bill it's it's uh um
Senate bill
463 from
2024 which
became uh 2024 laws two chapter 296
section 6 and what section six says
is
um the that the effective
[Music]
dates of hang
right the the effective date um
that the changes made by that law to the
requirement to appoint councel to
represent the expressed interest of a
child um would be pushed out that under
the original bill it became effective on
excuse me this proposal I guess from the
governor would extend it by two years to
2028 yes I really respectfully I really
think that this should go over to the
CFL committee to look at because this
bill underwent extensive revisions and
whatnot and it has a lot to do with the
children who were outplaced out of state
I don't know if you guys remember but
over at the bled sod Center who were
really going some re undergoing some
really abusive situations and we need to
make sure that stuff like that doesn't
happen I mean they were in a rat
infested home being really abused so I I
really think that the the members who
worked on this might be better able to
kind of speak to it I I get that it's
that it is a costly item but I I think
where there were the ones who heard it
and worked on it we should really defer
back to them yeah no that's I I will uh
I will raise this with uh chair Pearson
and say you know maybe uh um you ought
to you ought to uh talk to to chair wer
about this
um all right
else you did have two
things oh can I yes of course represent
I just wanted to say that for those of
you who are asking about this document
that we're referencing chairman Lynn
emailed it to us on March 2nd and to all
the committee
members I'm sorry what did I what did I
send to every this this packet here you
sent this packet oh this packet yeah
yeah know I did send it out right um oh
okay so um the other thing I um the
have a nice day well you you too and
thank you so much Maya
for you were you were excellent during
our meeting for sure
[Laughter]
almost better than exactly exactly um so
um uh what was I gonna say
um the reports by tomorrow morning if I
could please um and uh oh uh we'll have
uh hearing on the our last two bills on
Wednesday and then we'll have our exec
session I hope it goes as quickly as
this one went I'm not quite sure it will
but I'm hoping um since 14 and there
were right we have were only nine today
only nine today um I just thought I'd
mention right right and so uh we will it
sounds like I I need to I need to make
sure of this uh um but it sounds like we
will have a meeting on the
19th uh it probably that will be the O
the the uh budget assistant performance
audit on the Human Rights Commission
will probably be the only thing on the
agenda because we've now heard and will
have exec all our bills so it shouldn't
be long we'll probably start at 10: and
you know but and you will you will each
get a
copy of the
audit
and make sure you have make sure you
have a glass of wine with you when
before you start reading it it is really
tough reading very tough reading and
this is all this was all transpired at
the request of the Judiciary
Committee did I have my I read mine or
chance
that um all right do we have any uh yes
representative Manos um Mr chair I
believe you mentioned there were two
performance Audits and um I I thought
you had said that and I was just
wondering if you could clarify what the
other one is if there isn't oh no I'm
sorry I think the only one that I'm I
miss no it's just they're performance
aics all the time and they're excellent
but for this committee I think it's just
this is the only one right all
right right all right any um any other
business all right I I no I think we're
adjourned and thank you to our
substitutes for for your being here we
appreciate it very much thank you very
much all right but as as to the
performance audits that were adjourned I
would say to you I hope that reading
this you will get caught up in their
value and from now on each time that
another one is produced that you read it
because the quality of the work is
superb and it really helps to inform
what we're doing here all right thanks
everybody